[Music]
I've been having some really annoying
dreams regarding from my mother-in-law
personal relationship kind of dream you
know yeah awkward that may be the
understatement of planet Earth I mean it
was awkward you're going to have to make
a decision that I don't want this in my
head
anymore what in the world is going on
this is John with the Dr John deloney
show greatest mental health and marriage
and parenting show ever ever
recorded says my mom Hey listen I'm so
glad that you're here on this show we
talk about mental health we talk about
marriage we talk about parenting we talk
about all a bunch of hard stuff real
challenges that real people are going
through these are your neighbors these
are the people sit by you at church
these are the people that work with you
these are you real people struggling
with real stuff it could be mental
health it could be emotional health it
could be about your marriage your
relationships falling apart it could be
about the wildest situations
imaginable my promise here is that I'll
pull up a seat next to you and I'll sit
with you and we'll figure out what to do
next if you want to be on the show give
me a buzz at 1 1844 693 3291 it's 1-
1844 693 3291 or go to john.com
askk and by the way if you send me a
long DM if you slide into my DMs I'll
say that all if you slide into my DMs
and you send me a long like um direct
message about like what's going on I'm
not going to answer it I don't answer
any questions like that on on social
media only um john.com askk or 1844 693
3291 um so if you want to be on the show
give me a buzz or write into the show
and we'll have you on um today today is
a special show we have added a jillion
new
listeners like an unfathomable amount of
listeners um every month we keep getting
these scores where it's the greatest
month ever and then it's followed by the
greatest month ever and it's the
greatest month ever and we are so
excited to have so many new people it's
such an honor that you guys are walking
with us and giving us your most precious
resource which is your time and so in
honor of all the new listeners and for
those of you'all who been OG's with us
right the OG 17 the original 17
listeners who just hung in there and
hung in there and hung in there we're
doing a very special Greatest Hits
episode we're going all the way back to
2021 with some of the wildest um a
little bit Jerry springish
calls to a if you were if you were with
us in 2021 a couple years ago you'll be
like oh gosh I remember this call I
forgot all about this call and if you're
new you'll be able to go whoa whoo like
way did they see my whoo and they're
going to have different Show graphics um
I'll probably be wearing different
things my hair will look ridiculous
but these are some of our greatest hits
from
2021 stay with us check it
out all right let's go
to Mark in Los Angeles California what
is up
Mark hi there Dr Loney thanks for having
me what's up man how are you I'm doing
all right how are you I'm doing good so
how can I help
ma'am so recently um I found out that a
few years before meeting my wife uh she
was working as an
escort and she had kept this a secret
from me and I can understand why she
didn't want me knowing about it she told
me she hated it it's something she was
ashamed of maybe a little traumatized by
it uh she did it for the money she had
debt and eventually she got addicted to
the lifestyle and continued to do it and
now we're married and we're expecting a
baby and I love my wife and I want to
accept it and move on but uh you know
it's kind of a tough pill to swallow and
I'm not even really sure how I should
feel about it and I'm just wondering how
I can move forward without that image of
the past tainting our
relationship and getting in the way of
our
marriage that's a lot
brother that is a lot thanks for sharing
that how long you been
married uh only a couple months oh only
a few months huh and how far along is
little
baby uh about 25 weeks 25 weeks wow okay
is it becoming real yet you're about to
be a
dad yeah it's uh definitely real but I'm
excited for it that's awesome
man okay
so you said you don't know how to feel
what you should feel about this so tell
me what do you feel about this be honest
as you can don't lie to me or yourself
or to the 17 or 18 listeners of this
show I think the first thing I felt
was don't don't start with I think how
do you
feel
I feel lied to deceived okay uh maybe
jealous okay
hurt
angry
yeah what
else uh I think I sorry I feel it's
definitely got in the way of my
trust yeah you
think yeah what
else
I don't know I think there's just so
many
different things going in my mind I
don't know where to even begin so just
begin don't overthink
it
yeah I'm saying just begin you're angry
you're pissed
off you're heartbroken you're just sad
what kept you from just what kept you
from just packing up and walking out the
door most of us the story we would tell
oursel is if one day our wife sat down
and said BT dubs I was an escort before
we um got married but it's all good
now pass the
syrup we would the story We Tell
ourselves that we'd be like I'm out of
there bro I'm out of you didn't do that
how come
uh I love her I mean we've had a good
relationship so far not the best it's
had its Rocky points but well was built
on
Liv you know what I mean so yeah I would
imagine it's like say man yeah the the
the our boat trip was pretty Rocky and
it's like yeah there's big holes in that
boat full of water can see
that um how long how long did y'all date
before you got married
uh it's been about a year now
okay
and so you love
her you've known her for about a
year you got married you're having a
baby what do you want to
do I I want to make this relationship
work this is something in our past and I
don't really have a reason not to I
don't really have a reason to believe it
was something that has happened since
we've been
together and she's been good to
me and I want to take care of the
family is she in on this
too yeah she's in
100% how'd you find
out so when we got married we had
uh our own hard drivve like our own
files on our computers and we put them
on to one and so just one day I was
going through and I found some old
photos and uh like
messages from the
agencies what was that feeling
like it was uh like my heart sank yeah
that's when you can feel your organs
fall out of the bottom of your you when
you're just sitting there and your
stomach
drops
so I found out and then I I asked her
about it that night and she was a little
hesitant she didn't want to talk about
it but uh since then she's
been completely honest as far as I'm as
I know
okay and I think the key here is as far
as you know okay so here's the reality
of your
situation and it sounds Sensational
right most of us don't wake up and uh
the person we married a few months in
lets us know or we find out that they
used to be um an escort right
prostitute that right um that doesn't
usually happen but almost always not
almost always but
often you wake up and you find things
out about your spouse they had a pass
they didn't tell you the fool of this
they didn't think to even explain that
that they didn't think this was a big
deal or whatever that happened to to be
so at the end of the day here's what
you're wrestling with you're wrestling
with two things one a shattered picture
of the woman you just married the future
mother of your kid and of this um this
um fantasy of marriage that you had
right and two you're dealing with a
significant violation of
trust so the violation of trust is
something you're going to have to lean
into be honest about and continue to
work towards healing right and she's
going to have to understand that she
violated that
trust if you say I forgive you if you
say I am fully in and I love you and we
are moving
forward then you're not going to be able
to beat her up on this deal you're not
going to be able to bring it up when you
get mad five years from now you're gonna
have moments of insecurity you're gonna
have moments of when she's late coming
home and you're going to have to choose
to not use those moments As Weapons
because you said I forgive you and you
said I'm all
in
and as part of the rebuilding trust
process you're going to be able to say
hey I'm just checking in you're late
coming home everything good and that
she's going to know that part of her
rebuilding trust process is being
completely open and not getting her
feelings hurt when you ask her to check
in okay you got a lot of healing to do
right and that's going to be frustrating
and hard and messy and you'reall going
to stumble through that but if you're
both all in you're both all in right the
second part of this is your picture
looks all screwed up right she's not who
you thought she was
yeah right we all have a past we weren't
all prostitutes but we all have a past
right that just sounded Bonkers to even
say out loud so what you're going to
have to do is sit down and with her and
co-create a new picture what this is
going to look
like
right and if you I'm with you she's a
person of value she's worthy of being
love too and if she's put her past
behind her and she's moving on in a
committed relationship with you and you
are the end all be all then she deserves
forgiveness and moving on just like
anybody else
does but there's a part of me that says
you don't trust her yet that you're not
ready to paint a whole new picture with
her included in it because she right and
so that's going that those building a
new painting a new picture together
building a new building and working on
that trust is going to be like an
Infinity signal it's going to work
together you have to keep working on
this keep working on it and then brother
you have to grieve because you had a
picture of what was and it's gone now
and now you know something new right
scales came off your eyes and now you
got a new new vision of what's what's
going forward and you're going to have
to grieve that man just be open about
it and so it's going to be hard yet the
the things to do are relatively simple
it's going to be getting up every day
and remembering to respect her and be
kind to her not weaponize her and love
her like she's your wife cuz she is like
she's the future mother of your baby
which she is and it's going to be honest
and open about rebuilding
trust so how does that sound does that
sound like something you want to do be a
part
of yeah you're you're right that uh that
trust is still hard to get back but I
think at this point uh
she is the future so I want to do
anything I
can so you mentioned something earlier
you said
uh you were jealous what does that
mean I
um just that image of that past
work it's I think it's getting in the
way of the intimacy
yep obviously I wasn't in the picture
mhm
but having that thought is it getting in
the way of your intimacy the you're
starting to put these images in on Loop
replay replay how do you measure
up how many were there where were they I
wonder if she tried this are you going
down that
road yeah all of that yeah so Hey
listen there is no fruit in detail
mining if she sat there and gave you a
rundown of every single trick she ever
turned she gave you a rundown and a
physical description of every person she
was ever with that wouldn't make you
feel
better and this is going to be part of
your healing process which is to let
some of that stuff go and what you're
going to have to do is
practice practice controlling your
thoughts when you go down those roads
because what's going to lead you to be
highly insecure
highly
frustrated never being able to be in the
present moment with her because the
moment that one thought Pops in your
head I wonder if she with somebody else
did this or I wonder if I wonder if this
could have then you are officially not
present anymore and you were somewhere
in her imagined
past
right right and so you're going to have
to work hard that when that image Pops
in your head you say out loud nope and
you have another image ready to go to
which is probably her staring right back
at you but we had this fantasy that if
we just know every detail all right good
it's not true the same thing happened
with folks um you know when somebody
takes their own life they want to know
why and what happened and man you can
learn all that stuff it never takes away
that hurt never takes away that that
feeling of loss
right and how does she respond when you
tell her that you're struggling with
things with thoughts of jealousy and
your imagination runs wild on
you she's pretty understanding uh but
it's not something she really enjoys
talking about it's gotten a little
little heated yeah and uh does it feel
good to bring it
up maybe at first but I I don't think it
ever ends well yeah you know what it's
like it's like throwing a punch feels
good and if it connects solid brother
man it feels good for one
second and then you see their look on
their face you see them fall to the
ground and you're takes over right that
H don't turn around this whole thing
around and you put yourself in some sort
of superior position and beat her up
with her past if you say you're all in
you're all
in you got to put your bricks down too
brother your bricks of insecurity your
bricks of not enough your bricks of
moral superiority well I never did this
you're right you didn't congratulations
you said I'm all
in
right right so in the same way that you
have to rebuild trust with her she's got
to rebuild trust with you slowly but
surely you're going to have to relearn
how to trust yourself you're going to
have to relearn how to treat people when
you get angry you're going to have to
learn some new behaviors and new skills
ones that where you
don't yell and raise your voice and get
all high and mighty and Superior and
yeah yeah yeah well you don't do any of
that and it's going to be a hard journey
for both of you and sounds like this is
relatively recent that you found
out this grief's going to come in waves
it's going to come in waves just like
the last
caller if y'all are both all in I have
no doubt in my mind y'all can heal from
this grow
and make this a powerful part of your
journey powerful
Story and there's also no doubt in my
mind that if at any moment one of you is
like dips her toe back in the water this
whole boat's going to flip right over
easy over you get to make that choice
brother man I'm all in on you guys good
for
you um I'm all in let me know how it
goes let me know how those hard
conversations go and keep me updated man
let us know when the baby's born and
we'll keep thinking about youall in your
journey hey delone here good folks our
society has devalued sleep we're told to
keep working and grind through the
fatigue and pretend that we don't need
sleep then this crazy culture tries to
shame us when we do hit the sack at a
normal time I'm here to tell you 7 to9
hours of refreshing sleep is essential
for all aspects of your physical and
mental health and to help with that I
recommend investing in an amazing
mattress getting great sleep is
priceless but a premium mattress can
cost a lot and that's a big reason why I
love dreamcloud dreamcloud mattresses
are made with premium materials for half
the cost of other premium mattresses
they use Advanced Technologies to keep
you comfortable all night for a great
price and the exclusive deal they're
offering my listeners can help even more
right now dreamcloud is offering my
listeners 40% off all mattresses plus an
additional $50 discount go to dreamcloud
sleep.com and enter code John deloney
today that's dreamcloud sleep.com with
code John
deloney all right let's go to Jack in
Kansas City Missouri brother Jack how
are we doing man hey I'm doing great Dr
D I really appreciate talking to you I
appreciate your calling man how can I
help this morning well I need to preface
my question with some serious gratitude
between you and Dave I mean just a huge
part of my premarital dating life to
prepare us for the realities and uh
manage our expectations for for marriage
and it just means so much to us my wife
is a huge fan of yours from day one so
it's an honor to talk to you well she
joins my mom as you she doubles my
audience so I'm appreciative of that
Jack so are you newly
married uh yeah um a month ago so uh I'm
52 and a month ago I married a
49-year-old virgin okay so is this your
first
marriage it is my second marriage second
marriage okay and I'm assuming this is
her first marriage exactly okay all
right so you're a month in and you are
52 so you're halfway home right and um I
don't know why I always go to talking
about death sorry about that but hey
you're living your best life at 52 you
got remarried and you married a
49-year-old who's never had sex
before right okay right I'm assuming
that's why you're calling yeah I mean
this is a unique situation so uh um I I
uh I feel like we're having some
intimacy challenges where we've had some
attempts to consummate and with varying
degrees of of success but um there's a
lot of fear um of physical intimacy
with her and I just need some tools and
knowledge to kind of help because she um
basically you know was single for so
long that she just kind of divorced
herself from that physical side that
pleasure was a foreign word I think um
so so she's kind of
reintegrating you know even that
language into that part of her life and
uh I I we knew this going in it's not a
surprise um we we just are going to take
our time with it but I'm just you know
I'm like who are you jack you're like
the greatest guy I've ever met cuz you
know what I was expect hey you know I
was expecting I was expecting that you
to
say what's wrong with my wife and you're
not you are asking me hey man how can I
grow how can I learn some stuff how can
I create a safe environment brother I'm
telling you right now if there's more
Jacks in the world we don't have all
this nonsense right so you've made my
heart feel good and I I I'm just
grateful to even be able to talk to you
today um just even your patience and
your kindness is awesome so a couple of
um broad basic questions here does your
does your wife have a history of trauma
or is she just never find the right
person and virginity was a was a thing
she wanted to hang on to and then
suddenly it turned turned into the late
20s and late 30s and then suddenly she's
almost 50 and then she finds the right
guy or did she have a history there that
she really needed to part ways with
intimacy and any sort of vulnerability
there that that's a great question um
she had uh the only trauma that really
uh played on her ability to uh form
relationships with people was you know
she poured herself into her work after a
death in the family okay and that was
hugely traumatic for her um and you're
right time Slipped Away um the
opportunities I guess I I hate to use
the word dried up that's such a horrible
term but um but the opportun life
happened right and we we live in this
world where uh if you don't if you don't
you know go to your four-year
undergraduate degree and then find
somebody and you'll date for 18 and a
half months and then get engaged and
then get married or you get your
master's degree and then you're 29 and
then if you don't follow the road right
there's something wrong with you right
and so I don't and yeah and her Purity
became part of her identity because I
mean it was obviously her uh you know we
wanted to do things according to God's
plan and she did her whole life so that
combined with everything else just kind
of ended up with her where she's at so
sure so um I guess my my meta question
is is she in interest in this does she
want to have a great sex life with you
and a intimate marriage and a fun
rambunctious um no holds bar
relationship with you I can't speak to
rambunctious but I can tell you that um
she wants a normal uh life in that area
okay I'm gonna tell you don't settle for
normal okay normal's boring settle for
rambunctious settle for two people that
um cultivate desire in one
another and yes so we live in this funky
place and there's several great books
you can read on on just the evolution of
marriage in fact me and my friend Rachel
are going to have a whole event on this
coming up in the next few months
um but we've traded in the last 30 to 40
years we've traded safety for intimacy
so you meet somebody and you're
attracted to them and your heart racist
and you can't just wait to make out
right and you practice safety is he
going to show up when he says he is is
she going to return my phone call um
that first time one of you gets sick and
the other one brings food by you
cultivate
safety and then what happens is you
begin to trade safety doesn't is is
butts heads with desire right to be
crass about it nobody wants to make out
with their mom or their brother right or
their or their sister that's safe I know
that person there is no desire there
none right um but there's safety and
then as you be as you feel safe with
somebody and y'all two are you know 50
you're halfway through life you all
understand safety you all understand
Independence you all understand those
things what they didn't tell us in
premarital counseling what they didn't
tell us in grad school they didn't tell
us this at all and our parents certainly
didn't model this because they didn't
know is that once you achieve safety
once you have the hard money
conversations and the 401 questions and
you make will together once you feel
safety then and it usually happens in
your 30s and begins in your 40s and 50s
especially you have to practice desire
you've got to cultivate desire as though
you are practicing safety early on in
your relationship and it feels weird to
practice desire because that's not what
Romeo and Juliet told us they said we're
just going to walk into a room and be
like oh my gosh there you are or you
know Jack and Rose they didn't you know
Jack didn't see Rose on the Titanic and
be like well we need need to do is to
practice intimacy no man they were like
making out in some weird car and then
they died to get well he died cuz she
didn't let him on the door like a sucker
he could have fit on the door but here's
the thing so they are they're you got to
practice it and it feels weird to put
sex on a calendar it feels weird in your
case to be intentional about going slow
and saying hey we're going to have a
relational goal of here and the moment
she feels unsafe she gets to call it and
then we're and we're going to go again
and you're going to have to practice
patience and you're going to have to
practice um what I like it's comes from
Emily nagasi I'm going to recommend a
book for you two guys to read together
um but you're going to have to practice
turning on all the ons and turning off
all the offs um intimacy especially in a
marriage relationship is so often
ecosystem related it's environmental
right here's a good example my wife um
likes to have all of the dishes done and
the kitchen and clean before anything
else happens in in the evening and I
became so insecure I started taking that
personally and I the the story I told
myself was she would rather have a clean
kitchen than hook up with this nice
piece of meat right and I don't know if
you can see me right now Jack I'm
smoking hot okay so I just I got to
where I was think I'm not really but I I
that's why I do radio I got to
thinking man I can't believe that she
would trade a clean kitchen over this
and it wasn't until we sat down and had
some hard conversations that I
realized she can't stop judging herself
she can't stop feeling a entire culture
that says if you don't have a kitchen
looks like this if you don't have a
heart that looks like this if you don't
have a period at the end of these
sentences you're not a true wife you're
not a true mom you're not a true fill in
the blank right I didn't know all that
baggage that comes along how much it
sucks to try to navigate the world as a
working professional wife mother all
that stuff it's hard and so dude what I
decided to do is stop taking it personal
and then I try to clean the kitchen man
if that's if that's what it is dude I've
got you on that right and it took us
having this conversation about what's
the environment look like what are the
offs and what are the ons the book I
want you two to read this is not a
faith-based book um you mentioned that
y'all are both Christians and you have a
Christian ethic this is not a Christian
book it's the best book I've ever read
when it comes to talking about um
establishing estabish establishing
good grief James we need a dictionary on
the show
establishing um sexual intimacy right
and so a Blow by the parts that you
don't like but there is an extraordinary
discussion um and it's written for women
but it's called Come As You Are by Emily
nagoski and um it is exceptional when it
comes to I've heard you recommend that
book before I'd recommend y'all both
read it together and it will probably
make her blush it will probably give her
Freedom here's one of the ultimate um
thesis of that book life is too short to
not have an incredible sex life it's
just too short life is too short to
pretend that guys just have a sex drive
and girls just have a a sex drive light
those are not true either of those are
not true they're not real and so she
cuts through a lot of the myths and then
she gives you a lot of tools for how
couples can grow together and learn
together and um how women especially can
learn these offs and on and the and the
brakes and the gas pedals which is a
different met metaphor than drive it's a
great book for you all to read together
but it's going to give you common
language and that's what youall need
here it sounds like brother you
have a a heart of safety a heart of go
slow and so what I want to do is give
her some tools and give her some
permission to don't use the word normal
in your house anymore you got it yes
we're not going to be normal there's
nothing normal about y'all two by the
the way right there's not you're not a
normal guy the the heart and compassion
you have for your wife isn't normal um
her being a 49-year old virgin is not
normal I guess I say not normal it's not
common right that's a better word to use
it's not common in y'all's decision to
love each other recklessly with abandon
and I want every single 50-year-old
couple listening to this show I want
every single 40y old couple 30y old
couple mid 20s year old couple I want
you to get into the mindset of
establishing desire Romeo and Juliet
lied to you that's not real that was two
temp teenagers throwing a temper tantrum
that ended up in a murder suicide thing
it was it's stupid it's not real what's
real is is cultivating desire
cultivating mystery cultivating a spirit
of I refuse to have anything less than
an a just a rambunctious extraordinary
sex life with my husband or my wife I
just don't and so what we have to do to
get there and for that looks different
for every single couple anyone who tells
you like well you should be idiots you
work it out together y'all build this
together so Jack I love your
heart I was going to tell him to call me
back you don't need to call me back Jack
I'm I'm I'm curious on all 50 different
levels don't call me back on this one I
love you and I'm so glad I got to talk
to you today
brother this episode is sponsored by
better help hey folks Delon here
sometimes we know what good for us but
it feels like we just can't make
ourselves do it like our brain's getting
in its own way and that happens to me a
lot and I'm pretty sure it happens to
you I know I should play a game with my
kids instead of practicing my guitar all
night but sometimes my brain tells me
that hey maybe that metal band's going
to call after all you got to get your
practice in therapy helps me figure out
what's holding me back from doing what I
know I should do and it can help you too
so your brain can begin to work with you
not against you sometimes it's just as
simple as talking things through and
learning how to intentionally Place
guard rails between yourself and
negative behaviors we call them
boundaries so if you're thinking of
starting therapy give better help a try
better help is flexible because it's
totally online so it can fit your
schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with the
licensed therapist you can switch
therapist at any time for no extra
charge make your brain your friend with
better help visit betterhelp.com SL
delone today to get 10% off your first
month that's betterhelp
hp.com all right let's go to Joseph in
Cleveland Ohio what's up brother Joseph
how are we doing good how you doing Dr
John you know what I was gonna come up
with something clever I don't have a
clever thing so I'll just say I'm doing
pretty good man man sometimes you just
jump and then there's no water in the
pool that's just what happened right
then so what's up man I feel that um I I
feel that awesome I can already tell
it's G to be a fun call so what's
up um I've been having some really
really reoccurring annoying dreams
regarding myself and my mother-in-law
okay um more of an intimate personal
relationship kind of dream you know yeah
awkward makes it awkward you know I can
I'm not going to imagine it but I'll
take your word for it how about that
yeah yes that works um
it's gotten so like frequent that the
point that like even when I'm trying to
like you know not be there mentally
in when I'm awake and around my family
and it's just frustrating because it's
like I've talked with my wife about it
she's cool because it's like it's a
dream it's not like you're doing
anything so hey hold on all things just
stopped every digital like zero and one
just stopped turning just now you told
your wife about this how'd that go
it was awkward but my on I relationship
that are like Hey listen that may be the
understatement of planet Earth like
I I mean it was awkward yeah no I know
this has nothing it was more Awkward for
me because
like her mom is one of those people that
like her friends in high school would
make comments to her about her mom so
it's like she's beautiful she has grown
yes okay and so your your wife has had
to deal with this forever right yes okay
and I wasn't weird when I said anything
to my wife about it like she completely
understood she's like you're not the
first guy to have a dream and it just so
happens to be like about my
mom hey hold on like you're being for
real that's a real conversation youall
had yeah and she was just like cool man
she was like hey it's it's just a dream
you can't control what you dream about
as frustrating as it is and as as realis
it is it's not real but like listen I
don't know what you I don't know what
you did in another
life but you married so well every day
of your life you should get down on both
knees and just be like thanks
man yep and she like my wife is an angel
on Earth and she's yep 37 weeks pregnant
and and she's 37 weeks pregnant yes sir
wow okay so um man we're not even
talking about the dream I just can't
even believe
one you're brave and you're like one of
the core principles of the show man is
that Secrets destroy relationships and
right when you told me that I thought oh
my gosh man just the tension that would
be in your home you had enough courage
to to say that and you may have had
enough courage to say that because um
sounds like your wife is a just a really
remarkable human being so um when you
say recurring they're happening how
often are these dreams
happening probably once every other week
okay and how often are you in proximity
to your
mother-in-law pretty frequent like we go
to the same church we have dinner with
them at least once a week like okay
we're very close to my wife's parents
okay and so it keeps happening and
you're now starting to feel awkward in
the real
world yeah because like I'm I'm about to
be a dad to a daughter and I am just
like
it's awkward for my own mental space
because my brain is just like yeah oh
hey remember that dream that happened
last night and I'm like I would really
like to not think about that over
Thanksgiving dinner right now thank
you yep everyone in the United States
just nodded their head and they were
like yeah I could pretty much see that
yeah we're all with you on on this one
Joseph all right so is this dream a
replay is it essentially the same um
narrative every time is is it different
don't get gratuitous man I I I don't
want that stuff in my head but walk me
walk me
through different scenario same end
result okay all right so here's the
thing good for you and your wife sex
dreams are almost never about sex they
are intimate dreams are almost never
about intimacy they're about I mean they
can be about a million different things
but they're often about being accepted
being deemed worthy being deemed up to
you know that you've got a valued place
here and so what is your relationship
like with your
mother-in-law fantastic okay like she
has said she's made comments to my wife
that she thinks of me like her own kid
um we're very close and like she talks
to me and my wife a lot about stuff
going on in her own personal life and
not nothing like too in detail just
like she talks with us and we have open
conversations and
it's yeah so there's no hierarchy
there's no rule you're not walking
around feeling like uh I'm not I didn't
I didn't she's disappointed in who her
daughter married everybody's rocking and
rolling and feeling great about life
yeah okay so here's two things one um
I'm not a psychologist and psychologists
spend time interpreting dreams and most
people tell you dream interpretation is
voodoo right it's got some reality but
usually it's the reality is what how it
makes you feel so that's my question to
you are you carrying shame around about
this are you annoyed by it are you
frustrated by it um do you like it like
what's going on in your heart and your
head
here D all of the above okay that's the
best way that I can answer that um like
everything that I love about my wife
it's she got from her mom okay um but
she's not your
mom no no she's not her mom yeah that's
what I meant yeah she's not her mom yeah
I I get that and it's like it's just
unfortunate that like the person that
I'm married to has all these great
qualities that her mom also has and it's
just like it's not unfortunate yeah I
was like say why is that unfortunate
sounds awesome hold on it is it's
fantastic because they're great people
it's just
I don't want that image of my
mother-in-law you know okay so is do you
want to stop that
dream yes okay so I'm gonna I I know of
one thing that is from the the nightmare
research it's from Dr Joiner and he's an
extraordinary research suicide
researcher but um he walks through a
really a clear step-by-step path on how
to deal with nightmares and this isn't a
nightmare this may not work this is the
best I've got and what I would tell you
is in short order if this doesn't work
you need to go see somebody um a
psychologist probably not a therapist
probably a psychologist who is going to
walk you through other things about this
dream here's the challenge for you is I
think you like having this
dream you don't like what it means for
you in the real world is that
fair yeah that's fair
and as long as you like having the dream
man it's going to recur and it's going
to recur especially if there's no power
Dynamic you're going to have to make a
decision that I don't want this in my
head anymore okay I honestly I don't
think you're there yet I think you're
more freaked out by it's kind of weird
and it's not super common you're
probably not going to call your buddies
and be like dudes guess what you're not
going to do that and right so it's more
you feel like a freak but you like it
and until you decide I don't don't want
this man it's going to keep looping back
on you but here's here's the rundown
okay
um you have to rescript this is the way
Dr joinor calls it you have to rescript
this in writing okay so you have to
write out the
scenario and then you have to write out
an alternative
ending so let's say you are um I don't
know you come home to your house and
your mother-in-law's there and there's
nobody else there and every time you
have this dream it always ends with a
certain outcome right you're going to
rescript this you're going to see that
your mother-in-law is there you going to
choose to get back in your car and
you're going to leave and then you're
going to go somewhere else and then when
you get home your mother-in-law's not
going to be there anymore she's not
she's going to quit showing up and then
throughout the day after you have
written this down you have to run this
narrative through your head multiple
times you have to practice it on a
regular basis okay he would say you have
to retell the new version of the dream
throughout the day
okay and what it does it it resets your
mind it it it creates A New Path for
this dream to head down once that ball
gets um pushed down the hill does that
make sense
yeah tell me if I'm crazy I don't think
you're going to do
that like do the writing things
out
it sounds fantastic and I would love to
not have this dream anymore I really
would
really yeah okay I mean I I'm
fundamentally a guy and it's like I know
biologically great whoopy do but like
mentally in where I want to be with my
wife like because we want to be pastors
and like I don't want any crap holding
me down you know yes I do um my guess is
there's other things here that we can't
handle on a show have you been to
counseling
recently no why do you laugh at that no
it I sorry we're working through uh Dave
ramy's baby steps right now and it's not
in the budget for counseling and stuff
so here's what also is not in the budget
divorce here's what also is not in the
budget an absolute train
wreck between your mother-in-law and you
and a new baby girl and all of the
derivative mess that's going to happen
Okay M you don't have money not to do
this but my guess is you've got stuff in
there that you got to talk talk about is
that fair or am I crazy no that's
probably Fair okay so here's the thing
you have a more connected relationship
than probably anyone I've ever heard of
you're you're the first person I I have
ever heard that in my life that would
have told their wife what kind of dreams
you're having okay so I want to high
five to you and high five to your wife
awesome awesome awesome that's a great
Foundation to start
from I also think you've got some demons
in there you've got some conversations
you need to have with yourself with your
past with your with your legacy with
your heritage
there it's worth going to spend some
time with a counselor okay especially if
you're going to take on a job your job
is to care for other people the third
thing is man I want you to try this I
want you to sit down tonight by yourself
you're not going to show this to anybody
and I want you to rewrite this script
rewrite it and then for the next week I
want you
to fold this piece of paper up put in
your pocket and go through it a few
times a day I show up at my house I walk
in my mother-in-law's there I say hey
I'll see you later you turn around get
back in your car and you drive away and
then a couple hours later pull that
piece of paper out when you think about
it read through this script make a
mental picture of you walk in the house
you turn around and walk away and do
that several times do that several times
do that several times and then when you
have if the dream goes away great Dr
Joiner is the smartest guy ever and um
you're healed and I'm G I'm probably
going to just start a dream show after
that if
not um then you're right back where you
started you don't lose anything right um
and then you can have something else to
talk about with your
counselor but man that's a big deal it's
a it's a big deal and and here's the
thing you said it best at the beginning
and I want to make sure everybody hears
this number one when it comes to dreams
don't ever feel embarrassed or secretive
or weird maybe in this case right I was
going to say never have secrets I mean
if you're dreaming about your
mother-in-law your father-in-law maybe
hang on to that one yourself maybe don't
bring that home and just be like hey
everybody um I would probably say in my
house I'm having some really disturbing
dreams that I don't want to talk about
but they're really making me
uncomfortable and um I may go talk to
somebody about it because they keep
showing up and they they're happening
every other week every other week every
other
week if you're one of the most common
things I I hear is hey my wife had a a a
dream an intimate dream about an old
boyfriend or had an intimate dream about
somebody at work or something man be
it's hard is it's going to be be curious
not judgmental right that doesn't mean
she wants to cheat on you that doesn't
mean she's dreaming about her ex-boy I
mean she's literally dreaming about her
ex-boyfriend but that doesn't mean that
she's pining away for her ex-boyfriend
right and vice versa it's almost never
about that
person right but sitting on them creates
Secrets which create division which
creates then you find out that you are
way far apart from one another way
down
um opposite
roads but man hey I want you you to
Joseph I want you to try this and let me
know how it goes um man we'll be I'll be
thinking about this one for a minute
man hey what's up deloney here listen
you and me and everybody else on the
planet has felt anxious or burned out or
chronically stressed at some point in my
new book building a non- anxious life
you'll learn the six daily choices that
you can make to get rid of your anxious
feelings and be able to better respond
to whatever life throws at you so you
can build a more peaceful nonanxious
life get your copy today at John
del. all right so that was The Greatest
Hits volume I don't know 33 volume one
Kelly saying volume one volume
one I think it's greatest it's volume
six for you OG 17s and all you new
listeners thank you so much for being
with us I'm gonna end today with Kelly's
favorite song the song that she sings to
me after we're off
air actually she calls my answering
machine regularly and it's super
weird my phone answering machine what do
you call it voicemail good gosh okay God
you're old this isn't 1980
man I say you can leave a message after
the beep and it goes beep and I hear
this
John did you ever know that you're my
hero you're everything that I'd like to
be John I can fly higher than an
eagle because you are The Wind Beneath
My Wing every day y'all every day love
you guys see
[Music]
you